[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans dimanche
sont politiques 2h30 de grand oral
devant les français devant la presse
emmanuel macron a répondu il y à la
colère des français
il a annoncé un certain nombre de
mesures mais tient à garder le cap des
réformes engagées déjà depuis deux ans
le chef de l'état veut diminuer les
impôts il veut faire travailler
davantage les français il veut renforcer
la décentralisation il veut également
laissé un peu plus de place aux citoyens
dans la démocratie quand pons nos élus
locaux on va leur poser à la question
avec nous sur ce plateau eric alauzet
bonjour un jour député la république en
marche du doubs merci d'être avec nous
mais face à vous marier à dominique
aubry conseillère départementale pour la
haute saône pour l est républicain
également candidate aux élections
européennes bonjour bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous face à vous il ya
martial bourquin sénateur parti
socialiste du doubs du côté du pays de
montbéliard bonjour bonjour une très
heureux de travailler ou très heureux de
vous recevoir et puis julien audy
bonjour à vous faisait du rassemblement
national va être conseiller régional est
également candidat pour les prochaines
élections européennes merci merci d'être
avec nous vous pouvez réagir tout au
long de cette émission vous le savez je
vous rappelle le hashtag dit mme paul fc
chemin avant de parler de la
décentralisation ou de la démocratie
nous allons parler du nerf de la guerre
emmanuel macron veut baisser les impôts
sur le revenu ont l'écoutent veut pas de
hausse d'impôt je veux des baisses pour
ceux qui travaillent en réduisant
significativement l'impôt sur le revenu
j'ai donc demandé au gouvernement de
mettre en oeuvre cette baisse d'impôts
en la finançant par la suppression de
certaines niches fiscales pour les
entreprises la nécessité de travailler
davantage et des réductions de notre
dépense publique
[Musique]
alors une baisse des impôts de 5
milliards de prévu mais emmanuel macron
a prévenu les français devront
travailler davantage il n'a pas évoqué
la possibilité de revenir sur les 35
heures ou d'enlever un jour férié non il
serait plus question d'allonger la durée
de cotisation pour les retraites et
réalisé une première question est ce
qu'on n'a pas donné d'une main pour
reprendre de l'autre
vous savez de toute façon le budget de
l'état il est ce qu'il est il peut
changer l'année suivante dix ans après
mais un moment donné il est ce qu'il est
donc quand on choisit des priorités de
soutenir telle ou telle catégorie c'est
forcément des vases communicants il n'y
a pas de baguette magique
en l'espèce effectivement il ya une
baisse d'impôts cat annoncé on enverra
les détails pas comprendre que c'est sur
les tranches à 15 30 et et 40% de la
classe moyenne celle qui a d'ailleurs
été beaucoup mis à contribution dans les
deux dictatures précédente
j'étais un peu perplexe parce que il ya
déjà 10 milliards qui ont été annoncées
au mois de décembre le 10 décembre
c'est la première fois qu'il ya une
annonce aussi importante 5 de plus
bon c'est pas facile à verte alors
effectivement posé la question
effectivement du financement alors il ya
la fin des niches fiscales sur leur
entreprise sur les rats musqués
il ya aussi la continuation de la baisse
de la dépense publique qu'on peut
optimiser à il s'agit pas de baisser le
nombre de fonctionnaires on y reviendra
peut-être
et puis effectivement il ya la question
de la durée du temps de travail alors
sur la durée totale sur la semaine on
travaille autant en france qu'ailleurs
on n'est même plus productifs sarrière
le chercheur nature et travailla
retraite plus tôt et alors non seulement
l'âge légal est plus précoce mais en
plus on part même avant l'âge légal
parce que pour les tas de raisons
d'ailleurs
donc c'est là que le sujet est posée et
de la retraite à taux plein qui a 62 ans
est malheureusement difficile à
atteindre pour bourbon
on commence à travailler plus tard donc
quand on est jeune marie dominique aubry
l'est républicain le demandait ça là-bas
impôts c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pour vous alors la baisse d'impôts oui
c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est une annonce qui va t'elle
concernés à quelle hauteur comment
va-t-on la règle et il fallait faire
important mais tant qu'à bouger quelque
chose tant qu'à bouger et à baisser les
impôts et bien que l'on simplifie un peu
l'impôt sur le revenu et surtout que
l'on réponde à la demande vraiment du
peuple et que ce soit beaucoup plus
équitable et plus simples et qu'on leur
distribue de manière différente
c'est vraiment une grosse réforme vous
appelez martial bourquin sûr ça alors là
sur la baisse des impôts mais aussi sur
l'allongement de la libéralisation
première remarque il ya impôts et taxes
les taxes ne cesse d'augmenter
l'essence est à son plus haut niveau à
chaque fois qu'il y à une hausse de
l'essence
le prix des taxes ne cesse d'augmenter
les français vont devoir payer 6 %
d'augmentation d'électricité au mois de
juillet donc vous il valait mieux revoir
les taxes plutôt que le laisser là on a
affaire à une des crises sociales les
plus importantes de la vème république
et le chef de l'état avait une nécessité
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il gère cette
crise et qu'elle arrive à un compromis
pour qu'elle s'arrête j'ai l'impression
qu'après ce qui nous a dit hier ça va
s'aggraver finir moi vous êtes vous
aider parce que attendait sur le pouvoir
d'achat
pas grand chose si ce n'est rien sur la
démocratie
on renvoie au local à on va en parler
tout à l'heure la démocratie ont
finalement rester sur le côté connu sur
nous elle nous disait tout de suite mais
comment un budget ses budgets
pourquoi il a donné autant d'argent aux
plus riches pourquoi il a retiré les 10
sf il est plombé par son son quinquennat
il l'a plombé tout le début en faisant
en sorte dourdan de l'argent aux plus
riches
et ça c'est insupportable si les audi
pour vous ce qui a été annoncé hier soir
ça sera pas suffisant la crise va
continuer écouter les français ont
compris seulement 37% sont convaincus
par ces annonces
de toute évidence mails macron n'a rien
vu ni rien entendu
alors daniel contre 1 et n'a rien appris
de la même rencontre
quand on voit ce qu'il annonce après six
mois d'une crise inédite une crise
sociale d'une ampleur inégalée depuis
mai 68
on a des français partout dans nos
territoires qui se sont levés
étranglé par les impôts et qui ont crié
on n'arrive plus à vivre de notre
travail on n'arrive plus à boucler les
fins de mois
là pour le coup la baisse d'impôts c'est
quand même une bonne chose non puisque
la baisse des impôts
comme vous l'avez dit il va donner d'une
main ce qui va reprendre de l'autre et
ensuite cette baisse d'impôt de 5
milliards
mais le concernent qui elle ne concerne
pas les gilet jaune qui ne sont pas
assujettis à l'impôt sur le revenu ce
qui aurait convenu au gilet josé
d'accord la baisse des charges c'est la
baisse de la csg c'est la baisse de
l'acheter
aujourd'hui une partie des gilets jaunes
sont étranglés par la csg quand on parle
au titre des retraites la réindexation
c'est une bonne chose mais il faut quand
même le dire avoir l'honnêteté de le
dire ce que c'est docteur emmanuel qui
défait ce qu'a fait monsieur mister o
macron puisque c'est lui qui a des
indexées les pensions de retraite sur
l'inflation
donc tout ça c'est des mesures est tous
assez pour gagner du temps et encore une
fois fait insuffisant au regard de la
crise car dans ma main des mesurettes
non monsieur jalozai si vous voulez
faire des économies du milliard monsieur
à lausanne et vos économies cieux à
lausanne il ya énormément d'économies à
faire ou lutter contre les gaspillages
et déjà les 20 milliards sur la fraude
sociale
les 17 milliards sur l'immigration les
10 milliards que nous voulons l'union
européenne avec les contributions paris
dominique aubry pour vous il y avait la
balle la baisse de la csg s'était séparé
fallait s'attaquer aux taxes plutôt que
je pense que le message des français
avait été clair comment je peux vivre à
l'heure actuelle dignement avec mon
salaire
il aurait fallu mans je peux vivre
pouvoir maintenant je peux vivre
actuellement avec ma retraite
voilà ce sont les deux points qu
emmanuel macron a touché donc la demande
des français y répondre il a répondu
avec ce qu'il souhaitait maintenant je
serais tenté de dire que ce sont ce ne
sont pas des mesures ce sont des
annonces
nous n'avons rien de concret et de
définitif milliards qu'il est milliards
d' annoncer concrètement pour la
personne qui tous les jours se lève le
matin pour aller travailler comment
retrouve-t-il se retrouve-t-il 5
milliards qui va être impactée par ces
mesures
face à ces mesures et on lui - ces
annonces eric alauzet une question aussi
par exemple sur l'île sf
c'est le bouquin l'évoquait est ce que
ça vous est ce que ça aurait pas été
finalement une des bonnes solutions de
remettre y est c'est fait aussi pour
apaiser la tension aurait permis oui
c'est symboliquement très très fort moi
je financièrement aussi trois milices et
3 milliards
ça faisait des mesures d aide pour les
mesures d'être de combien on a
ponctionné les français martial bourquin
quand nous étions tous les deux de la
majorité - d'après saison bien plus que
3 milliards 10 à 15 milliards et comme
toi comme moi tu as voté ses lois ses
mignardises et s'effacer à gauche
génération aulas n'a pas parlé tous a
même fini c'est après midi ça je pense
que monsieur bourque est un petit peu
oui c'est pas tous en même temps sinon
tensions entre les annonces du 10
décembre
et maintenant faut pas les oublier c'est
18 milliards qui ont été restitués aux
français parlez vous les mettez en face
des 3 milliards les 3 milliards je vous
dis si tu si je vous réponds que vois un
je n'ai pas voté 2 c'est mon amendement
qui a été validé pour évaluer yassef
donc on verra si ça marche on a
effectivement ça permet de faire mieux
fonctionner l'économie
mais là c'est bien 18 milliards côté
restituer aux français à 3 milliards de
plus ce serait bon à prendre
je suis bien d'accord avec vous malgré
une question on va continuer sous
serment on parle des retraités moi je
voudrais voilà je voudrais vous poser
une question sur les retraités martial
bourquin notamment donc il ya le retour
de l'indexation des pensions de retraite
sur l'inflation il ya aussi quand même
1000 euros le minimum vieillesse qui va
être remis à 1000 euros pour tous les
retraités qui auront cotisé on va dire
toutes leurs années est-ce que ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle
tout ce qui contribue à lutter contre la
misère est une bonne chose
simplement ce sont des des commandes et
des créations extrêmement vague
extrêmement heureux c'est quand on est
comme les 5 milliards donnés mais
comment le faire on va le voir comment
le finançons valoir simplement ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que lorsqu'on parle
salaires il n'y a pas que le budget de
l'état je vous donner deux exemples
premier exemple on parlait du sfc quand
même 5 milliards à peu près chaque année
qui peut être remis
5 milliards à peu près deux fois la
deuxième chose si le cic eux on l'a fait
pour les entreprises voilà on l'a mis en
place et c'est bien on s'affaire choix
on s'aperçoit que aujourd'hui il faillit
mettre quelques exigences ses exigences
à pourrait être quoi pour nos pme
c'est le bienvenu c'est bienvenu le cic
eux par contre pour les grandes
entreprises qui délocalisent pour les
grandes entreprises qui ont des chiffres
d'affaires qui qui manie l'optimisation
fiscale
est ce qu'on n'a pas à nu s juguler les
choses congrès sur ya pas il n'y a pas
de contrepartie et dernière chose
lorsqu'on va demander du salaire c'est
pas des primes qu'on veut c'est du
salaire mensuel sur sa fiche de paye
pour qu'on puisse aller vers la banque
et avoir des crédits c'est pas une fois
ou deux fois une prime pour le coup
cette régie à quatre reprises qu'ils
payent c'est trop gros qu'est ce qu'un
raté emmanuel macron dans son débat
c'est de ne pas avoir mis en place un
grenelle du pouvoir d'achat et de la
consommation
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'il ne veut
pas changer de politique parce que c'est
tout pour les plus riches est rien la sq
après on va passer à la décentralisation
bon je suis pas dans de grandes annonces
je pense que ce qui était important ce
n'était pas de faire des annonces avec
dix plans des grenelles etc
je pense que les gens en ont ras-le-bol
je pense que ce qu'il demande c'est de
la justice sociale c'est de l'équité et
de la simplicité
il n'y a rien je termine les retraités
les retraités
ce n'est pas la génération dorée après
tout ils ont quand même mérité ce qu'ils
ont là ils l'ont mairie il le mérite
maintenant quand on demande aux français
de faire des efforts eh bien ces
attributs déjà ses efforts et quand on
parle parce que on se dit comment on
finance tout ça est bien quand on
demande le financement ses efforts
contre les attributs qu'est-ce qui avait
proposé pour limiter cette dépense
publique
le train de vie de l'état on vous
demande de réduire le vôtre les français
on leur dit réduisez votre train de vie
qu'est ce qu'on demande à l'état on va
parler justement de l'état avec les
fonctionnaires on a en en alors très
rapidement rapidement son exemple et
bien sûr la suite aimé le maquereau ne
change pas sa politique
il consent finalement
à taper les petits riches mais ils
refusent de taper les super riches avec
le rétablissement du vsf qui encore une
fois est une mesure première des gilet
jaune qui la met de côté et encore une
fois c'est toujours la même logique
culpabiliser les français des fainéants
qui ne bosse pas assez alors que nous
sommes troisième pays en termes de temps
de travail alors que nous il ya juste la
grande-bretagne l'espagne qui sont
devant nous aujourd'hui les français
travaillent les culpabiliser est
inadmissible et c'est pas avec cette
logique là qu'on arrivera justement
améliorer si on va en venir à la
décentralisation puisque c'était l'une
des annonces également forte hier des
manuels macron un retour un nouvel acte
de décentralisation avec notamment là on
va dire le développement puisque ça
existe déjà en franche comté à des
maisons de services écouter le président
dans chaque canton
en moyenne on pourrait avoir un lieu où
sont regroupés l'accueil pour le public
de services de l'état on propose aux
collectivités locales dgct être aussi
présenté à tous les opérateurs
[Musique]
marie dominique aubry je me tourne vers
vous puisque vous êtes conseillère
départementale en haute saône ça existe
déjà les mêmes les maisons de service
est ce que c'est une bonne idée ça déjà
les airs d'étendre sa à tout le
territoire
est-ce que ça a fait cette prof tu es
déjà il y en a à peu près une vingtaine
sur l'ensemble de notre territoire et je
dirais que débat il est pas est ce
qu'elles ont eu lieu des troupes à elles
sont là elles fonctionnent bien mais moi
je pense qu'il faut plutôt aller sur la
simplification des démarches
administratives c'est ce qui au lieu et
vu un seul énoncé par le chef de l'état
ce qu'il faut pas parler de petits
riches de grands risques
soyez au simple je pense que les
français attendent des mesures simples
c'en est une
simplifions un peu les démarches
administratives on en parle depuis des
années mais allons-y et au moins on
aidera et on responsabilise en même
temps les français eric alauzet vous
êtes également au conseil municipal est
ce que c'est une bonne chose de redonner
du pouvoir des responsabilités on parle
notamment de réattribuer un peu plus de
responsabilité pour le logement pour le
transport justement aux collectivités je
restais une démarque du discours d'hier
on a beaucoup reproché au président sa
verticalité
là on n'est plus reparti sur de
l'horizontalité en redevenant plus de
responsabilités effectivement aux
territoires locaux puisqu'on n'a pas
et de nouvel acte de la décentralisation
en mettant en avant les maires en
donnant plus de hauts fonctionnaires de
vision de la réalité du territoire et en
donnant plus de pouvoirs à la base aux
citoyens à travers la possibilité de
pétitions locale plus en plus affirmée
et donc cms ap maison de services au
public on a une à planoise ici a besoin
d'une à une vingtaine je crois dans les
joueurs remarquables
c'est le rural mais c'est aussi les
quartiers en déprises où il ya des
difficultés
et l'idée c'est d'avoir plus de services
je crois que le front-office au contact
de la population et de faire des
économies à l inverse sur tout ce qui
est centralisé en haut de l'échelle a
quand même bien passé donc le discours
puisqu'en même temps on enlève des
services dans les hôpitaux il y à des
manifestations on le voit les mouvements
pour défendre l'hôpital public pour
défendre les services publics
est-ce que là on va revenir en arrière
est ce qu'on va renforcer ses services
clés moi j'étais centre et mon rapport
cette année sur la loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale parce que je suis
rapporteur pour avis sur la qualité de
vie au travail
et effectivement j'ai mis en évidence
certaines de souffrance au travail en
particulier dans le milieu hospitalier
dans les ehpad donc encore plus
notamment connaît la problématique des
aides-soignants donc là il ya un vrai
effort à faire j'ai l'impression que les
circuits financiers
c'est un effort financier bien entendu
il ya dans la santé un secteur que je
connais bien beaucoup d'économies à
faire beaucoup d'examens redondants qui
le servent à et des examens qui ne
servent à rien dd met des traitements
qui parfois sans même ça on y reviendra
dans ses économies à faire pour
améliorer les dispositifs humains au
contact de nos concitoyens et aux
notamment par rapport au vieillissement
et je rends hommage à paulette guinchard
qu'une sphère jeu à ce moment là précis
martial bourquin est pour vous ça c'est
une bonne chose alors de redonner du
baume à dire des responsabilités du
pouvoir la crau a commencé par mettre en
cause les corps intermédiaires et
notamment les élus municipaux les les
maires il n'est pas allé au congrès des
maires la l'affrontement avec les deux
grandes associations étaient presque à
son paroxysme et là ils semblent ils
semblent changer de braquet il semble
réfléchir en disant je ne peux pas faire
sans ce bien sûr tous les présidents de
la république savent que dans une
société aussi complexe que
société française on ne peut travailler
qu'avec les corps intermédiaires
bien sûr les élus bien sûr les
associations bien sûr l'ensemble des
corps intermédiaires les syndicats
notamment est là que se passe-t-il on
nous dit on va faire des mais ça paie
dans chaque maison de services en les
maisons france service écoute et vous
savez ce qu'il va se passer avec la
réforme darmana ces temps ci c'est moi
si les dg la dgf va disparaître des
territoires d'exploration générale des
finances a les finales chez nous par
exemple dans un canton comme audincourt
c'est quasi mais est ce que vous croyez
pas que justement chaque daïra retour
sur ces mesures
chaque fois que c'est ouvert c'est
quasiment plein pour demander des
précisions pour rediscuter des choses et
tout ça on va éloigner ça il y aura
peut-être plus qu'à besançon ou à
montbéliard et aujourd'hui cette
direction générale des finances
publiques un peu partout j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a chez emmanuel
macron une idéologie l'idéologie c'est
le marché doit tout régler ça veut dire
le marché doit tout régler adp doit être
privatisé ses rares cheveux comme s'est
privatisé
alors que à toulouse ça s'est planté les
autoroutes c'est un gouffre financier
il continue il ne bouge rien sa
politique et on est dans une situation
très simple c'est que il ne va rien
changer et il a fait du blabla pendant
deux heures pour essayer de meublés et
faire accepter sa politique il ira
doutes sur cette question de la
décentralisation
moi je veux savoir de quoi on parle
puisque ça fait 30 ans qu'on nous parle
de décentralisation date de
décentralisation la fracture
territoriale entre les territoires
ruraux et les villes elle n'a jamais été
aussi profonde
alors là il ya des mesures qui ont été
annoncées notamment pour les jeunes les
annonces de travail en ville et qui
pourrait aider dans le tien sûr mais ça
c'est des belles annonces voient la
réalité la réalité des faits c'est que
depuis le début de son mandat et belle
macro à mépriser la france d oublier la
france des territoires la ruralité les
corps intermédiaires s les élus locaux
ou même une bonne chiens ont été
considéré que la décentralisation qui
ont été considérées comme responsables
millefeuille territorial alors qu'ils
n'y sont pour rien aujourd'hui il ya des
économies à faire sur ce millefeuille
il faut retrouver de l'ain
simplicité de l'efficacité et de la
proximité nous considérons assemblée
nationale c'est que tu es la commune
notamment pour la proximité le
département pour l'efficacité l'état
nation pour la sécurité il faut arrêter
avec ces pays ces communautés de
communes toutes ses agences régionales
et j'en vois énormément à la région qui
compte 1 fognon de dengue et qui ne
servent pas nos concitoyens il faut
simplifier on va passer à la dernière
partie de cette émission on va parler de
la démocratie c'est l une des grandes
revendications c'est toujours l'une des
grandes revendications d'ailleurs des
gilet jaune
le fameux arik le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
ce ne sera pas le rythme ce sera le rip
le référendum d'initiative du coup qu'il
sera renforcée on écoute tout de suite à
ce sujet emmanuel macron est ce que je
souhaite c'est que dans le cadre de
notre réforme constitutionnelle nous
puissions aller plus loin sur le
référendum d'initiative partagée qui a
été créée il ya maintenant 11 ans dans
notre constitution en en simplifiant les
règles en permettant que l'initiative
puisse venir de citoyens un million de
citoyens qui signerait une pétition et
qu'elle puisse prospérer en projet de
loi et si elle n'était pas examiné par
les assemblées aller au référendum
[Musique]
martial bourquin qu'il fallait un rique
peut-être pour apaiser justement la
contestation la crise que traverse la
france
emmanuel macron à verticaliser le
pouvoir à l'extrême et en verticalisant
et en personnalisant le pouvoir avec un
certain alors on a toujours eu un
président de la république très fort
mais avec un allié fort c'est mon cas
c'est même assez fort mais aussi avec
parfois des insultes aux français
écoutez ces thèmes et même des
provocations mais le riz qu il fallait
remettre au pas il ya il ya eu un
mouvement contre 7 verticale
verticalisation du pouvoir mais surtout
on s'aperçoit des défauts de la vème
république
nous avons besoin de démocratie
participative elle mouvement des gilets
jaunes
il a deux grandes revendications le
rétablissement de sf et deryck et on
pouvait sur des grandes questions comme
adp avoir un référendum si la famille au
grand débat alors qu' il a fait des
grands débats pendant des heures dans
toute la france c'est parce qu'il
connaît le résultat d' avance des
français sont contre la vente des bijoux
de famille et donc elle n'a pas vous
parler d'un cas particulier mais c'est
vrai que ça peut m'attendait je suis à
de nombreux ados prendre l'argent ou
retraités pour le donner aux
milliardaires
vous pensez pas que ça méritait un rique
là dessus et avoir un référent
qu'ailleurs le référendum d'initiative
populaire permet tout de même aux
français de soumettre au parlement faut
savoir qu'on peut le faire actuellement
sur adp qui est un brillant avec quatre
millions et demi il va falloir avoir si
l'avion est donc ça serait un million à
ce que ça c'est une avance lors on verra
si c'est comment si ces mises en place
rapidement
je souhaiterais que ça soit très
rapidement et qu'on puisse pour adp mais
simplement sur des grandes
revendications y compris sur des grands
sujets il aurait fallu il avait bien sûr
et s'unir est génial de le sur cette
crise il faut compléter sur le
référendum d'initiative partagée qui est
comme une escroquerie démocratique c'est
à dire que à partir d'1 4 million de
signataires donc citoyens à partir d'un
certain nombre de
signate de parlementer à 4 me dont on va
descendre et on annonce un bien
simplifie un petit peu quand même très
bien
sauf qu'après qu'ils aient le dernier
mot au bout de six mois
si l'assemblée nationale donc mais
seulement si la réf alors on sait ce
qu'est proposé manuel mata les attendait
6 à l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée
nationale
cela passe pas devant le peuple donc le
peuple ne va pas s'exprimer selon la
réforme constitutionnelle de 2008
alors là c'est ce qui va changer eric
alauzet pour vous ça n'a pas changé il
faut bien le dire donc sur adp
si la majorité parlementaire en marche
décide au bout de six mois de remettre
adp à l'ordre du jour elle sera votée
par la majorité est en marche et les
français n'auront pas s'exprimer les
récuser sur serez qu'il ya beaucoup de
sujets sur lequel on n'a pas eu détaillé
hier les il y aura des évolutions les
grandes familles connaît pas encore donc
on peut pas dire d'un côté il n'y a pas
d'annoncés quand il ya des annonces
c'est de la poudre de perlimpinpin c'est
des discours totalement contradictoire
donc hier c'était l'orientation la
direction maintenant faut travailler
dans le détail pour qu'effectivement il
ya une vraie opportunité pour nos
concitoyens de s'exprimer y compris sur
des sujets nationaux
on verra dans le détail quand on aura
les informations comment les choses
peuvent se mettre en place et ce qu'il
reste que le fond c'est alors s'est
certes donné plus la parole de nos
concitoyens mais ceux-ci rétablir de la
confiance de la part de nos concitoyens
envers leurs élus et là quand même
on n'a pas l'impression à bien marcher
tellement de chemin on a des questions
là notamment sur la prison en vue de la
prise en compte du vote blanc qui est
passé à la trappe ça c'est michel qui
nous qui nous interpellent et qui nous
dit ça va pas nous a incités à aller
voter oui bon le président s'était donné
ces explications sur proposition de voix
là dessus c'était simple à m j'aimerais
bien que ça que therrien des cinq mois
moi je pense que sur la méthode vous dit
bon on est toujours en train de répondre
de façon c'est l'un contre l'autre
moi je pense que dans les ronds points
ce qui a été dit quand les français ont
des revendications
je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle emmanuel
macron hier soir n'y a pas répondu
puisqu'il sait il s'est affranchi d'un
certain nombre de précisions dans les
halles ans qu'il a effectuée alors quand
moi vous savez je suis conseillère
départementale mes concitoyens il faut
redonner de la crédibilité aux
politiques et bien les concitoyens je
les rencontre chaque jour mais c'est moi
terme on a cotisé un an quasiment plus
et si on y arrive a zo les comptes ont
été plutôt quotidien marie dominique
wavre et quelle est la mesure qui vous a
marqué en bien ou mal la mesure qui vous
a marqué il n'y a pas de mesures il n'y
a que des annonces il n'y a eu c'est
grave parce qu'il ya eu hier soir que
des annonces c'est très imprécis et jeu
est ce que les français attendent et ce
type de réponse je ne suis pas sûr eric
alauzet pour vous la mesure la mesure
peut-être la plus importante en bien ou
en mal
18 milliards au total depuis décembre
par rapport aux 3 milliards dsf qu'on
évaluera si ça marche pas il faudra leur
mettre c'est quand même 18 milliards des
retraités sont largement beaucoup
d'entre eux sur largement dit satisfait
de ce qui a été fait heureux heureux
pour eux et puis le conseil de défense
écologique enfin on va demander à chacun
partout là où il est dans tous les
ministères tous les organismes de l'état
qu'une décision aucune décision
comme il ne soit prise le soient prises
sans on en croit le débat
ça vaudrait a noté martial bourquin la
mesure pour vous je pense que si
emmanuel macron voulait rétablir la
confiance
il remettait hier lisf et ils entamaient
un large débat je suis le pouvoir
d'achat des français
il ya des français qui travaillent
beaucoup il ya des français retraités
qui vivent très mal
de plus en plus mal et il fallait ouvrir
cette conférence du pouvoir d'achat un
grenelle du pouvoir d'achat pour
redonner de la confiance
sellal rapidement mercia l'âge et andré
la mesure avec vous bayrou est passé
totalement à côté du peuple français il
faut que le peuple français ne passez
pas à côté des élections européennes
pour réveiller ce président somnambule
qu'il ya une mesure qui veulent qu'une
aucune il a refusé le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
il a refusé le rétablissement des sdf il
a refusé la tva à zéro pression sur les
produits
merci qui merci à vous tous d'avoir
participé à cette émission c'est la fin
on a bien compris on ne m a pas d'accord
en tout cas sur cette conférence de
presse
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et
passer un très très bon dimanche sur
français
[Musique]